The most unique thing about Tijuana’s biggest
shelter for the so called Caravan migrants
is
that it provides hardly any shelter at all
– at least not from the elements, not from
the rain, and not from the cold during freezing
nights.
Designated by city officials to hold a maximum
of just 2500 people, this place now houses
more than 6000 migrants.
And in a few days that number will swell further
to 7,000, including more than one thousand
babies, toddlers and young children.
We meet Cindy Pinera again.
When we talked to her about a week ago, she
had just arrived with two of her four sisters
and without her father.
The family had gotten separated on their journey
to Tijuana.
Now, they are reunited, but conditions here
have dramatically deteriorated…
We’re in really bad shape.
As you can see everything is wet.
We are tired, we couldn't get any sleep last
night.
It's hard when the babies are all wet.
It’s getting worse for us with no real place
to stay.
This tent is not even mine.
The city of Tijuana, some state agencies and
an increasing number of NGOs are doing what
they can to cope with the situation.
Infections and diseases are on the rise, head
lice are a problem, overall hygiene is a major
concern.
Tijuana’s mayor says he is battling what
he calls an “unprecedented humanitarian
crisis” in his town.
– with almost NO help from the central government
in Mexico City.
It’s people we’re dealing with…who’s
going to be responsible?
Mexico City has finally sent more federal
police and some military to Tijuana.
But that doesn’t solve the city’s financial
problems, as it spends almost $30,000 dollars
a day on its migrant crisis.
A fortune for the border town.
If you know someone who wants to help… here
in this office.
Tijuana - Help Wanted!